>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Bilal Qureshi: It's a
great honor this afternoon
to have Laila Lalami here with us,
the author of The Moor's Account,
but more importantly, you
know, she has many other things
that she does including she's a
nonfiction essayist who writes
as a critic at large for the Los
Angeles Times and as a columnist
for The Nation, so she both is
an incredible imaginative writer
but also engaged with what's
happening in our world now,
so welcome to the National
Book Festival.
>> Laila Lalami: Thank you
very much for having me.
>> Bilal Qureshi: I just want to
say a little bit more about you.
You were born in Rabat, educated in
Morocco, Great Britain and the US.
You have recently received
the Guggenheim Fellowship,
is that right?
And you're working on your new book.
But the Moor's Account which was
your last novel not only was it
listed for the Booker Prize
but it was a finalist
for the Pulitzer Prize.
It's been an incredibly
well-received book.
And I wondered if you
could tell us a little bit
about the history behind the actual
history that inspired this book.
>> Laila Lalami: So, some years
ago, I was just reading a book
about Moorish Spain and
I came across a mention
of a man named Estebanico
who was said
to be the first black
explorer of America.
And I though to myself, "What
do you mean first black explorer
of American?"
That it seems like
a fascinating story,
I need to find out more about it.
And it turns out, he was part
of the Narvaez expedition
and had been written about by
a man named Cabeza de Vaca.
And I had heard about Cabeza de
Vaca of course, but I hadn't heard
about this fellow Estebanico.
And so, that's really
what drew me in.
I was curious to know
more about him.
And it's really an
absolutely fascinating story.
So the Narvaez expedition left
Spain in the spring of 1527.
And after a number of adventures
eventually landed near what is now
Tampa Bay in Florida
in the spring of 1528.
And a group of men was sent ashore
to sort of reconnoiter the area,
they had spied an indigenous
village from their ships and so,
they decided to disembark there
and they were sent to the village
to reconnoiter, and they
found a little nugget of gold.
And then Cabeza de Vaca's
relation of the Narvaez expedition,
that nugget of gold is
described as being small enough
that it could fit in
a child's rattle.
And so, because of that, Narvaez
gave the order to disembark
which is this long process that
involved moving the horses ashore,
moving all of the supplies
and the 600 people
that were part of that expedition.
And so they spent a few days in that
indigenous village which by the way
at this point had been
emptied of its inhabitants
because the people had
spied the ships in their bay
and they decided very wisely
to flee the village and wait
and see what these invaders wanted.
>> Bilal Qureshi: And
this is Florida, right?
>> Laila Lalami: Mm-hmm.
And so they found a few more
traces of gold and at that point,
Narvaez made a very faithful
decision which is that he decided
to split the expedition into two.
And he decided to send a land
contingent inland to go look
for more gold and to
send the other half
of the expedition back home
the ships and to go meet them
at the nearest Spanish port which he
believed was only 20 leagues away,
in fact it was more
than 1000 leagues away
so there was this big
mistake in navigation.
The navigation was not yet
an exact science at the time.
And so, these men, they all decide
to go inland to look for gold
and it seems kind of crazy when
we think about it today like,
"Wait, what are you doing?
Why are you all going
to look for gold based
on these tiny little nuggets?"
Until you realize that this
is really all tied to the sort
of personal history of Narvaez
himself who was a contemporary
and in some sense is a
rival of Hernan Cortes.
Hernan Cortes, the man who
conquered Mexico had departed Cuba
without actually securing
any of the proper paperwork
and so Narvaez was sent in pursuit
of Cortes to try and stop him
and to convey to the Mexican emperor
that Narvaez was actually
the rightful messenger
from the king of Spain.
And so, when he actually
landed in Mexico and try
to stop Cortes, Cortes defeated him.
And not only did Narvaez's
men desert him and join Cortes
but Narvaez lost his right eye in
the confrontation and thereafter had
to wear a black eyepatch.
So imagine what it must
have been like for Narvaez
to have been the man who was
sort of left out of that big,
big prize that Mexico was and so
then when he landed in Florida,
he was in no mood to wait
or to make these decisions.
So as soon as he found gold, he
decided to send all the men inland
to look for it and of course
there is no gold in Florida.
And within a year, there are only
four survivors for this expedition.
And the reason that we know
about this expedition at all is
because it was written about some
years later, many, many years later
by Cabeza de Vaca who was the
treasurer of the expedition.
And it really is the only--
or the first narrative we
have of Spanish exploration
of North America, so it's a
very, very valuable document.
And it contains a lot
of ethnological detail
about some tribes that
are now extinct.
And as I was reading this
document, I was just really,
really struck by all
of the silences in it.
So for example, there are no mention
of any women even though
these men end up--
the four survivors end up
spending merely a decade among
indigenous people.
And I was struck by that but also by
the fact that even indigenous men,
there's only one of them
that's mentioned by name.
The rest are known only as tribes
as groups, not as individuals.
And even this man who I was
really interested in, Estebanico,
he is named-- he is
mentioned about half a--
I mean, about a dozen times in
the book, half a dozen by his name
or the name that the Spaniards
give him which is Estebanico.
And the other half by-- he's just
called the slave or the black man.
And I was just really interested in
sort of that silencing in history
and how it promoted certain
myths about Spanish exploration
that it was the province
of white men
that native peoples
were silent in it.
And that even the people of
color who were involved were sort
of cast aside even though this
guy played a really important part
in that expedition in the sense
that he learned indigenous languages
and sort of became a de facto
translator for the others.
And so I was really just
intrigued and I thought
to myself wouldn't it be
interesting to retell that story
but from the point of
view of this one member
of the expedition whose
testimony was never collected.
The other three survivors actually
had their testimonies collected
in front of an official body.
But because he was a slave,
Estebanico's testimony
was never recorded.
And I actually thought that that
perspective was the most interesting
one because he was neither
a conqueror nor a conquered.
He was sort of an interloper.
He was someone halfway
in between and I thought
that that particular position made
him interesting to me and I wanted
to write a book from his
perspective about this--
>> Bilal Qureshi: Yeah.
And what you've done is not only
imagine the arrival in America
but also his entire back story in
Morocco and leaving his family.
And you've completely fictionalized
the story of what must have happened
as he boarded the ships
and why he ended up there
and the life that he's missing.
So it's kind of an interlace
narrative between both arriving
and remembering the past.
>> Laila Lalami: Right.
>> Bilal Qureshi: So it's a fully
sort of fleshed out vantage point.
>> Laila Lalami: Right.
Yeah, I mean, I wanted--
I thought, you know,
if I'm going to create
this character, there is--
he has his own life, his
own agendas if you will,
his own desires, his own ambitions.
The expedition is part
of that and it's--
the expedition is something that he
swept up in but it's not necessarily
at the center of his life.
So in a way, it's basically
moving the center away
from what the other book was doing
and then kind of saying, wait, no,
here is the story and
here is one way to look
at it that's completely different.
And the center of that story is
him, he's the hero, so it's really
about him and how he grew up
and how he came to be a part
of this expedition and what
happened to him afterward,
so it's kind of a decent train.
>> Bilal Qureshi: Well, it's
interesting too because I feel
like you must have
also thought so much,
you're also a contemporary
columnist and you write a lot
about what's happening in our
society now but I wondered
if you also felt that the idea of
returning the sort of vantage point
and returning the narrative
power to someone
like him was also a political act
in a way because in a sense, I mean,
this book comes at a time
when we're talking a lot
about who tells a story, why they
tell it and what we don't understand
when we don't hear it
from this perspective.
>> Laila Lalami: Right.
>> Bilal Qureshi: I just wondered
if that was informing you to think
about writing it now in
2014 or '15 when many
of us encountered the book.
>>
>> Laila Lalami: Right,
I mean, I think that--
yes, the story takes place in the
16th century but I was writing it,
I started writing it in 2009 and
it would be foolish of me to claim
that I wrote it only
with the knowledge
of what happened in
the 16th century.
As the author, I knew so much
more about the story and so,
even though I am limited in
sort of telling the story
from that character's perspective,
of course the whole idea
of telling it from
his perspective is
in a sense creating an
argument with history.
And I think that-- In general,
I think history is an argument
so it's basically saying like who
gets to tell the story in what way.
The facts in the book
are exactly the same
as in Cabeza de Vaca's history
of the Narvaez expedition.
What's different is the story
built around those facts,
the things that what glues these
facts together is what's different.
And I think that that
holds true today too.
So, whenever we tell these stories,
we're not just talking about facts
but we're looking at a
perspective on these facts.
So yes, it's absolutely true
that that was something
in the back of my mind.
>> Bilal Qureshi: You kept
a pretty interesting blog
and you keep it still on your
website and it was interesting
when you've documented the
story of researching this book.
You went to many of these places
and you photographed yourself there
and sort of what you were doing
and what you were discovering
as an explorer almost yourself.
>> Laila Lalami: Yeah.
>> Bilal Qureshi: Tell me
about the journey of kind
of not only visiting the City
of Morocco where he comes from
but then also the places in the
Americas that he have landed
and explored which probably look
quite different as in Florida.
>> Laila Lalami: Yeah, yeah.
I mean, and this is the thing.
When I came across the story, I had
the sort of light bulb moment I have
to write this novel, right?
And so, it was wonderful,
great, now you know.
But then, there's another thought
that immediately comes trailing
after that one which is, oh
my God, there's going to be
so much research involved in
this, I can't do it, right?
>> Bilal Qureshi: Special
events, yeah.
>> Laila Lalami: Yeah.
But, you know, the most
difficult part about all
of this is the first step.
Once you're engaged in the process
then it's just and everyday,
you make a little bit
of work towards--
>>
>> Bilal Qureshi: Were there
doubts at all at that moment
that you could imagine that is a
full flesh, fully fleshed out novel?
>> Laila Lalami: All the time.
All the time.
I really don't think that there is
any work worth engaging with that
that doesn't involve doubt.
I think it's actually
quite dangerous if I were
to approach all of
this with certainty.
The only certainty I had was
that I had to tell the story.
Everything else was
filled with doubt.
So, I obviously, was very fortunate
because I had a primary source
which is that we have this
document from somebody
who was part of that expedition.
But I also had a huge amount of
research that was done by academics
who were interested in the Narvaez
expedition and had drawn maps
so like I didn't have to go
and figure out what parts
of the United States
they probably traversed.
I could rely on maps that other
academics had already drawn.
And so, a lot of that was already--
a lot of that research
had already been done,
all I had to do was read it.
And so, I did read all of that
and then I travel to these places
to kind of get a sense of
what these places looked
like even though the truth is that
of course a particular place in 15--
say for example 1532 is
not going to look the same
as when you visited in 2012.
So of course the City
of Azemmour where he's
from is completely different
today but I can still gaze
at the fortress walls
that were built in 1513.
And I can still see what height--
I can measure my own height against
their height and that gives you--
that gives me a sense of what it
must have been like to stand there
in 1520 and to be transported in
one of those ships to go to Spain
as a slave and all of that.
So it was important to me to
be physically in these spaces,
but I think I also had to rely on a
huge number of contemporary sources,
sources from the 16th century.
And also just basic things like
figuring out the landscape,
I had to look up things
like plants of native--
I mean, native plant databases.
If you want to write
a scene in Florida,
you can't just put an orange tree
even though that's what we all think
of when we think of Florida
because there were no oranges
before the Spaniard showed up.
So, you know, it did involve
a huge amount of research.
And oftentimes, that research was
not a research I even knew I had
to do until I got to that point.
But if I can just tell you--
>> Bilal Qureshi: Please, yeah.
>> Laila Lalami: -- a
particular sort of anecdote,
there were many moments during
the course of doing the research
into the story where
my jaw would just drop
because I would discover some
incredible historical detail
and I would think, oh my
God, I have to include this.
But this is where writing fiction
is different from doing nonfiction
where you-- in fiction,
you have to be so choosy,
you have to really stay within
the perspective of your character,
what your character knew or could
have known, and it's just sort
of limit yourself through that.
So, it's just really
a lot of choices
at every step of the process.
>> Bilal Qureshi: The
other thing that I think--
well, one of the reasons I
noticed so many of the details
of the landscape and all of
the nature that you described
as they are doing this exploration
is the language that you've used
in the novel because it
actually does kind of read
like having discovered a
16th century travelogue.
>> Laila Lalami: Right.
>> Bilal Qureshi: Of course, and
it's almost like parched paper
and a feeling this is faded.
It's also in the writing, but
yet it also is very contemporary
and feels very modern,
it has a great sense
of storytelling energy to it.
So I wondered how you also
calibrate sort of the langue for it
where it would both sound
like we really had rediscovered the
Moor's Account and yet also felt
like a novel that was
written for us.
>> Laila Lalami: Yeah.
So a lot of that had to do with
sort of very deliberate choices
at the lexical level, so
choosing words that are still
in common usage today
but whose etymology is
at least dates back
to the 16th Century.
>> Bilal Qureshi: Some
examples of that would be?
>> Laila Lalami: So for example, an
example might be I can say commence,
right, that's something
that most people still use
or I could say start, right?
That's something that we use
today but in the 16th century,
you probably would go with commence.
Or, what I could not do,
I'll give you an example
of something I cannot do, is if I
say a troupe of musicians, well,
troupe with the T-R-O-U-P-E was
something that would have been later
and so I couldn't-- it would not
have been used in the 16th century,
or at least in that
decade of the 16th century.
So I know it sounds like,
"Wait, that's a lot of work."
But it's not in one step.
So you're writing a draft and you're
kind of trying to find this voice
and I was very much
inspired by several--
in terms of the voice
by several documents.
One travelogue is from the
16thcentury by Arab writers
for example, Ibn Battuta who
journeyed all the way from Tangier
which is his hometown all
the way to Asia and back
and among many, many other places.
And so, I kind of knew what a man
of that generation
might have sounded like,
and the kinds of things that might
have shocked or surprised him.
The "One Thousand and One Nights"
is a huge influence because I wanted
to have this-- the sense
of all these multiple stories
as opposed to chapters.
And also in terms of the style or
the sort of book hence to the book,
it begins like any other book of
the era with the Basmala which is
in the name of God, Most
Compassionate, Most Merciful,
that's how every manuscript began.
And so, that's what I
used as well and used
that in creating the
style of the book.
>> Bilal Qureshi: And for a novel
that, you know, again is a finalist
for the Pulitzer Prize, this is a
considered a great Moroccan novel
for the last few years.
I mean, you have put a character
of Muslim background in the sort
of center of your book, it is of
Muslim's subjectivity in the sense
that he is, you know, returning
in memory back to the faith
that he had to leave behind.
He still, while he's on this sort
of very Catholic Spanish mission
of exploration of conversion,
he's still remembering
that as a a part of who he was.
In your nonfiction work, you
do write a lot about the idea
of Muslim identity and you
had a recent long piece
in The New York Times magazine about
being a Muslim and the gray zone
and what that means
in our current times.
Tell me a little bit about
that as a part of your project
of you ever created project
and whether that was something
that you don't, maybe, like
talking about or you're just
like the subtlety living in,
or do you feel it was actually a
very powerful element in this book
that you wanted to build on.
>> Laila Lalami: I mean,
it's an interesting question.
I think that question came
up a lot because of the fact
that as the book came out,
obviously the character is Muslim.
And there's this whole sort
of a conversation right now
around the fact that Muslims
are sort of in America anyway
that they're sort of
outsiders, right?
So, that's how you can get away with
saying a Muslim ban and all of that.
And, of course, the reality
is that Islam has been a part
of the American history since
before there was a United States.
I mean, this guy was around in 1528.
And so, the idea that
Muslims are somehow foreign
to this country is
really one that the book
in some sense addressing
even though I never intended
to address it when I wrote the book.
The only reason I wrote the book
was because it was a good story
and I thought, wow, it's such a
great story, it's got adventure,
it's got transformation because you
have somebody who comes and he sort
of an interloper, he's not
a conqueror or a conquered.
And he has to kind of
completely reinvent himself
in order to survive in America.
They, basically all these four
survivors transform themselves,
into faith healers and I
was interested in that,
how identities sort of not
conditioned but influenced
by your landscape and where you are.
And I was really interested in that.
And it's a story of
survival so it's just--
it was a good story that was
why I wanted to write it.
But, of course, as
result of writing it,
this question of politics
comes about,
this question of Muslim
representation comes about,
this question was, well,
you must have had an agenda
of putting the Muslim in the
16th century to prove this thing.
And it's like, well, no,
I mean, if it proves it,
that was a byproduct to what I did.
>> Bilal Qureshi: Yeah.
>> Laila Lalami: It was not
necessarily an intent of the book.
>> Bilal Qureshi: But you
do have to have an agenda
when you write nonfiction
columns and essays, right?
>> Laila Lalami: Yes.
>> Bilal Qureshi: And I wonder for
you how does that toggling work,
how do you-- Do you take off and
sort of certain had them and have
to decide that now, I'm
going to take a much more--
yeah, a much more, a
stronger position on something
and make an argument for something,
and have your novels essentially
remain open for interpretation?
>> Laila Lalami: I mean, yeah.
I mean in that sense for me, fiction
is primarily driven by the urge
to tell a good story and by sort
of being completely hands off.
And if I've done my job right then
you won't know what I'm trying
like you won't know who I'm siding
within a particular story, right,
because I'm interested in delivering
as complex of the story as possible.
In the kind of nonfiction
that I write
and I'm not saying this is true
of all nonfiction but in kind
of like the kind of nonfiction that
I write which involves a lot of sort
of cultural criticism and
commentary, there, of course,
is more of a sense of me trying to
make sense of the world around us
and sort of telling you
what it is that I think
about and how I feel with.
So, in that sense, it's very
different like my agenda
if I have one is apparent and it--
because the columns
or the commentaries are
already telling you what it is
that I'm trying to say which
isn't the same thing with fiction.
>> Bilal Qureshi: And you tweet
a lot which is really kind
of fun to follow as well.
And you keep a pretty active profile
in social media and yet, you have--
you're a novelist and I also
wondered for you, how do you feel
about shutting out all of that
social media noise when you need
to write, because you're seemed
to participate in it as well so--
>> Laila Lalami: I know.
>> Bilal Qureshi: -- some
writers can detect this kind of--
>> Laila Lalami: I know.
>> Bilal Qureshi: --
I've said it all of
and I had to work on my book and--
>> Laila Lalami: Well, I wake up
in the morning, I drink a big pot
of coffee and I shut off the
world and I just go off in my room
and I just write my novel,
wouldn't that be lovely?
>> Bilal Qureshi: Isn't
that what you do?
>> Laila Lalami: I would love
to do that, unfortunately,
I feel like it's a luxury.
It's a luxury I don't have.
I mean, I feel just so
interested in the world
around me, so engaged in it.
I'm trying to understand it and
I find that the process of sort
of being in conversation
with it helps me think
through all a lot of these issues.
Having said that, I do find that
one when the time comes to work,
when the time comes to write
then I have to shut it off.
So, usually, I spend a couple
of hours in the morning sort
of reading the news,
like doing email,
all of that social
media, all of that stuff.
And then after that, I have
this program called Freedom
which I'll highly recommend.
So, it blocks the internet on
your computer and you can tell it,
if you want it to block it for
eight hours everyday 9 to 5,
whatever, you can program it.
So, I program it and that's
how all of my work gets done.
>> Bilal Qureshi: Well, you wrote
a really funny piece just kind
of describing how much you
struggle with procrastination--
>> Laila Lalami: I do.
>> Bilal Qureshi: -- and at first,
you felt super guilty for it
but now, you've embraced
it as part of your process.
>> Laila Lalami: It's just this.
I prefer to think of
it as my process
so I don't have to feel guilty--
>> Bilal Qureshi: So, it's not--
[ Inaudible Remark and Laughter ]
>> Laila Lalami: Yes.
>> Bilal Qureshi: And
you teach writing as well
so can you talk a little bit
about working with students
on their creative writing at
University of California Riverside.
>> Laila Lalami: Riverside.
>> Bilal Qureshi: Riverside,
right, exactly.
>> Laila Lalami: Yes, yes, yes.
I do-- I teach creative writing.
I mean, I enjoy teaching.
I find that as one character
and I think it was Disgrace
by J.M. Coetzee who puts it,
"He who comes to teach learns
the keenest of lessons."
So, I find that just the process
of teaching helps me kind of sort
out how I think through
pieces of fiction
or nonfiction because I teach both.
And I just-- I try to help my
students reach their full potential.
Not every student who takes a
creative writing class is going
to end up becoming a novelists
or a nonfiction writer,
but every student is going to
want to learn how to tell a story.
It's an extremely important skill.
I always tell them, look who is
the president of this country,
it's a pretty good story teller.
So, you need to learn how to tell
a story if you-- I mean, I just--
it's just an important-- I just
think it's an important skill.
So, I-- yeah, I-- we read where I
teach them to read like writers.
We discuss.
They bring in their work and
they-- we workshop it so it's fun.
I get to-- I get paid to
hang out with smart kids
for several hours a day so--
>> Bilal Qureshi: And I think
with the new generation of writers
that we now have emerging to--
there's an interesting
conversation I'd love
to hear what you think about,
which is also tied to the politics
of representation in your
book, who tells the story,
why do they tell it, and who
have we not heard in the past.
I feel like we're having a lot of
conversations around this issue
in the last couple of years
and even now especially.
>> Laila Lalami: Yeah.
>> Bilal Qureshi: What do you think
about these conversations
especially part of it is policing,
somebody shouldn't write
somebody else's story.
You've put yourself fully
in the mind and body of man
from the 16th century who's
exploring America, you know, you--
>> Laila Lalami: So, what do you
think my answers to that will be?
>> Bilal Qureshi: Yeah, yeah.
>> Laila Lalami: Right?
It's like, of course.
>> Bilal Qureshi: We we're
having this debate, right?
>> Laila Lalami: Right.
>> Bilal Qureshi: That the
writers who have not been able
to tell their story, it's--
they're they only ones
that can tell that story.
I'm just curious about--
>> Laila Lalami: Listen, I mean,
my view about this whole thing is
that whoever wants to tell a
story should absolutely feel free
to tell it.
You want to write about a 16th
century Swedish nun who goes
to China looking for silk, I don't
know, go ahead, by all means, do it.
The only question is,
how are you doing it?
If your method of doing it
involves something no more complex
than putting on a sombrero
and claiming
that you've created a
Mexican character then,
that's just not good enough.
And believe me, people
will tell you if they feel
that your work is delivering
caricatures and not characters.
And I think that the idea that
if somebody is telling you, wait,
I think that this is more caricature
than character is somehow
stopping you from writing
about that particular perspective,
that's just very misguided.
The whole point of freedom of speech
is that you get to say something
and the other person
gets to say something.
And so, therefore, yes,
everyone has the right
to tell whatever story they want
but then they have to be prepared
to hear whatever feedback
they're going to get
about that particular story.
>> Bilal Qureshi: Did you have to--
>> Laila Lalami: So, I
don't so much think about it
as somebody owning a
story, I think about it
as like how good is the story
that this person is delivering.
And the other aspect of
that is just because you--
and you have a particular ethnicity
or race or gender in common
with this character that you're
creating is by no means a guarantee
that what you're delivering is a
character and not a caricature.
It goes both ways, you see.
The proof is in the book
that you've delivered.
If the book that you've delivered
contains some sort of new way
of looking at the world,
new characters,
something really interesting
and rich and complex
that people find fulfillment
in then that's a successful,
you know, story.
But if you are delivering something
that's a cliche, you know, then,
of course, people are not
going to be pleased with it
and they're going to tell you so.
>> Bilal Qureshi: I should
have mentioned this by the way
but after this last question,
we're going to open this
up to questions to you.
I wanted to just ask you about being
in the international stage, I mean,
you're not only American
writer but you're also--
>> Laila Lalami: Yes.
>> Bilal Qureshi: -- you
know, Moroccan-American--
>> Laila Lalami: I know.
>> Bilal Qureshi: -- and
hyphenated and all kinds of things
and you write in French and you--
so tell us about the notion of being
an international American writer.
>> Laila Lalami: I know, isn't
that-- I confuse a lot of people.
>> Bilal Qureshi: Yeah.
>> Laila Lalami: So, I was born
in Morocco but I've lived now half
of my life in the United States
and I'm American citizen.
And yet, every time I do these
big festivals, I get put on--
No, no, I'm serious, I
get put on these panels,
they're all about writing
the other, you know,
or something like something
to indicate
that I'm not really
in the, you know--
>> Bilal Qureshi: Yeah.
>> Laila Lalami: -- sort
of middle of the road.
And I remember when The Man
Booker Prize's long list came out
and The New York Time said, five
American writers are on the list.
And that was the first
time that in print,
somebody had called
me an American writer
without saying a hyphen
of some sort.
That was the first time.
And the only time that it happened
was because it was British Prize
so it was necessary to distinguish
the Americans and to say,
those are our guys that
are dominating that list.
So, I though it was really amusing.
So, yeah., so, I don't
have a huge problem with it
as long as it is not limiting.
I think the problem in sort
of calling people a particular this
hyphen, not is that it can tend
to say that these writers are
different from these other writers.
So, here I am, you know, I
just told you this and now,
I'm on the international stage.
So, now, I'm apparently an
international Moroccan-American--
>> Bilal Qureshi: Right.
>> Laila Lalami: -- something.
She's different.
[ Laughter ]
And I think that's what
it's meant to suggest.
>> Bilal Qureshi: I don't think
this is the et cetera stage--
>> Laila Lalami: Yes.
>> Bilal Qureshi: --
but it's not exactly.
We want to open this up to questions
so please, come to the microphones
that we have here or we have
to pass them around as well or?
Sorry, OK.
You have to stand in the aisle,
there's a microphone there, sorry.
>> You ready?
>> Bilal Qureshi: Yes.
>> Laila Lalami: Hm-mmm.
>> Great. Thank you so much
for being with us today.
And thank you for taking us on this
wonderful journey with Mustafa.
My question deals with the
resolution at the end of the book.
And the reason why I'm asking that
is that there is much richness
as you go on this journey and
you introduced so many people
that I literally got up to the last
maybe within 10 pages of the book.
And I begin to wonder, how
is this book can be resolved?
Because I almost begin to
speculate is there a sequel
because there's much detail.
And when you then get to
the end, you realized--
>> Laila Lalami: Which
we're not going to reveal.
>> We're not going to
say anything about it.
It's more question of process.
>> Bilal Qureshi: Let's
cover our ears.
>> But it's a question of process.
>> Laila Lalami: Yes.
>> Did the book lead you to
this resolution that happens
within this very brief
period of time at the end?
Or did you actually have something
structured in your mind in terms
of how you would bring
it to conclusion?
>> Laila Lalami: Remember that
this is based on history so I kind
of knew where everything
was going to end.
And I knew from the beginning how I
wanted it to end, which believe me,
was a relief compared
with other books.
I knew how I wanted this one to end.
And so the answer is yes, I did
know where I was going with that.
Part of the reason you
might feel this way is
that it was very much a conscious
choice for me to keep the focus
on Mustafa and on what
happen to him.
The other characters in some sense
are not at the center of that story
and we find out through Cabeza
de Vaca what happened to them.
So, I wasn't so curious about what
happened to them after they all meet
and so, it was-- he was
my focus at all times.
>> Yes, thank you for coming.
I have not yet read your book
but I had a question
from the introduction.
You said that the character
had learned native languages
and served as a translator.
Did you address that
in the book as to how
that would happen and
then what detail?
>> Laila Lalami: So, one of
the things that was fantastic
about this character is that-- so,
I mentioned that he is from the city
of Azemmour which is
about 60 miles south
of Casablanca on the Atlantic Coast.
And what's interesting about
that city is that it's sort
of the indigenous people speak
a language called Tamazight.
And we also know that from
Cabeza de Vaca's relation
that this man spoke Arabic.
So, he speaks Tamazight, he
speaks Arabic, he's the slave
of a Spanish master which
means he spoke Spanish.
And Azemmour was a Portuguese
trading post which means
that Portuguese was sort
of the language of trade.
And it was Portuguese slavers that
ended up selling him into slavery.
So, he probably spoke his
books smattering of Portuguese.
So, before he landed in Florida,
he was already a multilingual,
multicultural character having
also lived in Spain briefly.
And so in a sense, it kind of
made sense that he was the one
that picked up on some of
these indigenous languages.
When I say that he spoke
them, I'm basing this
on what Cabeza de Vaca has
told us also about him.
And being able to communicate
in a language doesn't mean
that you need a vocabulary
of 50,000 words.
You can carry on a conversation
in English with about 800 words.
That's about how much you need to
carry on a regular conversation.
So, because he lived
with different tribes
and spent a significant
amount of time in it--
with each of these tribes, he was
able to communicate with them.
And Cabeza de Vaca tells us
that part of the reason why they
like having Mustafa be the
translator is they felt
that it gave them more authority
to have somebody be a go-between
like somebody that the
indigenous people had to come
through before they got to them.
But to me, that's the
opposite, it's upside down.
Of course, the translator is
the person with the most power
because the translator actually
knows what each side is saying
to the other.
So, it really was interesting to
me that Cabeza de Vaca dressed it
as sort of motive authority
whereas for me,
it seemed like he was the
one with the authority so.
>> Thank you.
>> Laila Lalami: You're welcome.
>> I read The Moor's
Account about a decade
after reading Cavesa de Vaca's
and really enjoyed how
much it followed things
like the near starvation, the
constant charity squash diet.
I should talk about your research.
How much were you able to find
in 16th century documents,
even court documents or
records of bills of sale
about how Mustafa would
have come to be--
>> Laila Lalami: In that expedition.
>> -- of that expedition
departing from Spain.
>> Laila Lalami: Well, I wish
that there had been a bill of sale
because then, we would
have been able to at least
to have a precise description
or age.
So, I had to do, in fact with his
character, a lot of deduction.
So, we know that he lands
in Spain in the 1527.
And I figure that no person who
is seriously engaged in conquest
and exploration is going to
bring a slave that's 75 years old
to wait on them.
So, obviously, it's a
young person's game.
So, I-- And even the durantes,
his owner was also in his 30s
so I figured, he had
to be about that age.
And so then, once I started going
back and thinking what was going
on in that city around that time
and suddenly, all these sort
of historical events
sort of fell into place.
There was the arrival
of the Portuguese,
the building of the
fortress walls in the 1513.
Then there was-- In 1520, there
was this huge drought which meant
that by then, there
was a huge abundance--
I don't know if that's
the right word--
availability of slaves because
of the drought and the famine
as a consequence of that drought.
In addition to which, there
was also an earthquake in Fez
which destroyed the City of Fez
and so there were refugees
that came from Fez.
And so, it's just like there was all
these turmoil going on in Morocco
that would have created
the conditions
for this particular person to
be enslaved and end up on one
of these Portuguese ships.
So, my research was mostly about
sort of Portuguese enslavement
of Moroccans during those decades
and what happened to the slaves.
And it was really incredible some
of the things that I discovered.
So for example, one year
because of the drought,
as many as 60,000 Moroccan women
were sold into slavery and brought
to Portugal to serve as slaves
and concubines to the Portuguese.
And so, it was just this really
like when you look at this
from the perspective
of 500 years later,
you see all these forces
working together that combined
to have created sort of this
critical mass for this expedition
for this man to be at
the place where he was.
Yeah.
>> Bilal Qureshi: Some
question here.
>> Yes. Early on and you've talked--
you mentioned large
silence is in the journal,
I think you mentioned
women is one example.
I just thought you might
like to elaborate a little
more what the silences were--
>> Laila Lalami: Of course.
>> -- and the significance.
So, the book tells us
about the Narvaez--
Cabeza de Vaca's book tells us
about the Narvaez expedition
and what happened to the
survivors over the course
of the better part of a decade.
And yet, not a single woman is
mentioned nowhere in the book.
And I thought, wait, that
makes absolutely no sense,
these people interacted
with indigenous people
including women especially
if they lived among them as
faith healers and all of that.
And so, once I start
thinking through this,
I realized that Cabeza de
Vaca's relation was published
in Spain in 1542.
And this was still when the
inquisition was going on.
And Cabeza de Vaca was a married
man who had left behind his wife
in Spain to wait for him.
And so that gives you an idea
of why the women are just left
out of the story because when, of
course, you bring in the women,
it will bring in questions.
So, he basically left the women
completely out of the story.
And so, that's why that
was something I wanted
to play with in my novel.
I thought my guy is not
under the inquisition
so he can talk about the women.
And so, that's why I endeavored in
every stage of his life to have--
so his mother plays a big role
in the book because she's the one
that basically teaches
him to be a storyteller.
And then when he is in Spain,
he develops a sort of friendship
with another slave who was a woman.
And then one state,
he arrives in America,
there's also other indigenous women
that get mentioned than named.
>> Hi. My question is about your
writing, your choice of language
to write and I know that you
grow up in Morocco as you said
where you learned Arabic and
French then subsequently English.
And I'm just wondering,
do you do any writing
in Arabic and French now?
And if not, why did
you choose English
as a language to write your fiction?
>> Laila Lalami: Sure.
So, yes, as you said, I'm
a native speaker of Arabic.
And I learned French and standard
Arabic at the same time at school.
And I learned the English
in high school.
I started learning English when
I was 15 and so it's kind of odd
that I'm writing, right,
in my third language.
So this is a question that
I get asked all the time.
And I think the answer is a
combination of it's just based
on like the way in which my life
has the turns that it's taken.
So, I remember, I was writing
in French when I was little.
I started writing when I
was about nine years old.
And that may seem a little
surprising until you realize
that a huge portion of
Moroccan literature is in French
because of the sort of
colonial history behind that.
Also because, I was sent to a French
school and so my earliest exposure
to literature was not in my native
language but in the language of--
in sort of the colonial language.
So, when we talk about who has
a right to tell a story, when--
imagine being a child and your--
the earliest books that you
see are things like "Tintin,"
right, or "Asterix," right?
And so, it creates a disconnect
in the mind of the child
in which the only people who inhabit
this fictional world are people
who are different than you.
They are not people with
whom you have any kind
of a cultural commonness
or linguistic commonness
or racial commonness or any kinds
of commonness, they're foreigners,
right, and that is what I saw.
So, in the world of the
imagination of the writer,
that was what was happening to me.
And so, when I started writing,
I started writing in French
and these are not things that
you realize when you're 9 or 10.
You're just wanting to write
about, you know, I don't know,
adventure stories or whatever
but you're not really thinking
about what's happening.
So, it wasn't until I was a
student in London some years later
that I started to think back
about all of these and to sort
of question the choice
of writing in French.
And by then, of course, as
I mentioned, I was not--
I hadn't been sent
to an Arabic school.
So, my literary Arabic
was not great.
I could read it just fine, I just--
composing in it did
not feel comfortable.
It did not feel-- I did
not feel fluent in it.
At the same time, I was also doing
a graduate degree in linguistics
and I will have to write all of
these research papers in English
so I have to do it anyway.
And so because of that, I thought,
well, I could try writing my hand--
throw my hand at writing in English.
And so now here we
are 20 years later so.
>> Thank you.
>> Bilal Qureshi: Unfortunately,
less than a minute left
but if you want to ask
your brief question--
>> Thank you.
>> Bilal Qureshi:--
we'll be able take it.
Yeah.
>> I just want to say, our--
my book club actually read
your book this month and so,
it's such a pleasure to
get to hear you today.
I'm wondering if you could
spend just a minute talking
about the indigenous groups that are
featured in the book and what kind
of research you are able to find
on those groups in the Americas
at that time, and how that
influenced your decisions around who
to feature and how to describe them.
>> Laila Lalami: Yeah.
And it's really-- Believe me
that that was of the things
that gave me pause about writing
this book is how do you even begin
to write about indigenous
people, right?
The first challenge is
that a couple of the tribes
that Cabeza de Vaca
mentions are now extinct,
which means that the only details
we have, the only details we have
about what they looked like and
where they found their livelihoods
and their ways of life come
to us from this outsider
who maybe understood certain things
but maybe also misunderstood
a lot of things.
And that is all we
have about this tribe.
So, those are the ones that
we're on Galveston Island.
So, it was just very difficult.
For those particular tribes,
I had no choice but to rely
on what he told us and I tried to be
as conservative as possible in terms
of how much of his-- the
details he gave us to use.
With other tribes, I was a little
bit more fortunate for example,
the ones in Florida had
survived until today so I had,
you know, materials about them.
And then, the other ones that were
in Texas, many of them are extinct
but I managed to find some sources.
And also, in one particular case
I managed to find like a glossary
that the last known speaker of
that language had left behind.
So, she-- one of the friars in that
particular mission had sat her down
and made her say what is
this word, what is that word
and written down what she had said.
So I had sense of what
the language sounded like.
Now, in terms of actually
writing the book, you have to--
I did not want to write a guy
who was a 21st century guy
who says all the right things
about sort of the outsider.
And so, when he lands, he
very much views himself
as a person of the Old World.
Even though he is Muslim and
the conquerors are Christians,
what they have in common is
that they both come from sort
of the same neighborhood
if you will.
And so for them, these
indigenous people are different.
And so when he arrives, his
descriptions are very superficial.
They have to do with what the
Indians look like and, you know,
where they fish and
things like that.
It's only as he lives with
them longer that he's--
that suddenly we're getting names,
suddenly we're getting
a little bit more
of life stories about these Indians.
And so, the thing that was great
about doing it this way is that I
in fact had a lot of materials
about the later tribes
than I did about the earlier ones.
So, it worked out that way.
But, yes, I did, of course, do
a amount of research on that.
>> Bilal Qureshi: Laila,
thank you so much.
>> Laila Lalami: Thank you
very much for having me.
Thanks.
[ Inaudible Remark and Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.